this is about families who have wealth
of $100 million a billion dollars these
guys you can't compete with them they
will get your stuff we're talking now in
2024 and we're we're on the back end of
really a golden 70 years or even in the
states maybe 100 Years of Living
standards for the middle class okay we
have lived through a period where people
like our parents have been able to
provide decent standards of living for
their kids on regular wages that is not
the historical Norm if you look at the
past 2,000 years of History most of
history is a small group of extremely
wealthy people and a vast mass of
extremely impoverished people and that
is because you get Dynamics like what is
happening now when you have very very
powerful people they can use that power
to buy the assets of less powerful
groups which at the moment is the middle
class in the government the only reason
we didn't have that is because for 100
years we taxed very rich people at
extremely high rates and that prevented
them from accumulating the rest of the
assets